Hi everybody! This is Mr. Duncan in England.
How are you today?
Are you OK?
I hope so.
Are you happy?
In today's lesson, we're going to talk all about...
...saying hello and goodbye.
When we first meet someone...
...whether it is a person we know or someone we are meeting for the first time,...
...we will normally use a simple sentence as a way of greeting them.
A greeting is a friendly way of opening a conversation...
...or as a way of letting the other person know that we have seen them.
There are many ways to say hello.
Hi!
Hello!
Hi there!
Hello there!
Hey! How are you doing?
Howdy friend!
What's up?
How's it going?
Wow! It's good to see you.
We sometimes use a double greeting.
For example,...
..."Hi there! Hey, how are you doing?"
"Hello! How have you been?"
"It's good to see you! How's life been treating you?"
Saying goodbye.
There are many ways to say goodbye.
Bye!
Bye for now!
Bye-bye!
See ya!
So long!
Ciao!
Later!
Cheerio!
See you around!
Farewell!
Ta-ra!
See you again!
Ta-ta for now!
Catch you later!
Goodbye!